jack give us a hand please bub
why because it's your favorite yeah
chicken wings okay all right let's start
off with the marinade tamarind paste in
first
all that into there all of that yeah
okay
good so two tablespoons of palm sugar
please is that like heated sugar
um it's a really good question it's a
natural palm sugar
and it's perfect for marinades how many
wings do you think you've eaten so far
at the age of 13. oh oh i eat
probably 50 a year 50 years yeah
something like that a nice sprinkle of
chilli flakes depends how hot you like
them
oh i love them hot hot don't forget the
girls you know they start complaining
when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food um i don't
know i truly love hot food
so in there we've got palm sugar
tamarind paste
chili flakes some garlic one nice
tablespoon
of fish sauce please this is looking
really good
isn't it and then a couple of
tablespoons of oil the marinade
in how nice little taste
not your finger jack
that's really good right wings in get
your hands in there and start
rubbing in the marinade please okay so
the
secret now is to coat the chicken wings
and all that marinade
yeah yeah how long do you leave them in
here
do you know what the longer the better
cover that with limp film wash your
hands
excellent good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
[Applause]
right so they've marinated now if you
take the tray out people
bottom one thank you and then we're
gonna put some tinfoil on there thank
you
so hold that in half
it stops them from sticking and that'll
stop
the wings from burning so from there get
them really dipped in
that marinade and try and get the wing
like that and just sort of
scoop it look like that so get that
really nice glaze on there
and then just yeah
so that garlic will roast and i got all
those wings
usually done i can make then ready for
the oven 170
25 to 30 minutes yep good man
excellent nice it's hot
wings are in right
to go with my ultimate southeast asian
dinner rice cooked in homemade
thai green curry paste for the easy
green curry paste
roughly chopped coriander
lemongrass green chilies
lime leaf shallots garlic
and ginger a glug of oil
and blitz the paste takes minutes to
make
but it'll keep for up to 10 days if
covered with oil and stored in a sealed
jar
in the fridge to awaken the flavors
lime roll to release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
heat the paste until aromatic add in
cooled or leftover rice i love using
fragrant jasmine rice
but your standard long grain rice is
great too
thoroughly heated through serve
thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this
it's incredible but simply add to
chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes
right now for the green beans beans in
uh bring the water to the ball what's
the first thing i should put in there
beans
salt salt so nice pinch of salt in there
yeah so make an amazing dressing two
nine tablespoons
yep of a crunchy peanut butter please
why is it crunchy
it'll give it texture and it'll be nice
and sort of
chunky green beans in okay got the rice
green beans we're gonna blotch them for
two two and a half minutes
what does blanching actually mean
blanching means sort of part cooking
okay i'm gonna blanch them in boiling
water yeah and then finish them
in the pan use the back of the spoon a
little bit easier
a teaspoon of brown sugar and she goes
nice is that a little bit too thick
maybe
yeah it is let's put a little touch more
soy sauce in there let it down
yeah yeah nice smell a little touch of
vinegar nice
i'm going to get a pan on now put my
beans
so a little taste did you taste it it's
so good
oh man hmm wow
so if you got the garlic like that i'm
going to slice the garlic down like this
keep the knife nice and flat that way
you'll slice through it
but take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first
just cut it in half okay your fingers
good
and then lay the flat side down so it's
nice and sturdy and that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good i'll drain the beans
nice a little tablespoon
of oil get the pan nice and hot
i'm gonna throw the garlic
good nice
mmm so fine i smell that already is that
lovely
so give that a little toss
so when you toss it push it down push
away
and pull back okay have a little go
push it down and gently take your time
nice so push down
and pull back up that's it nice so it's
getting nice
and golden brown green beans are drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans okay with the
rice
oh there's one of that oh wow
i want you now to spoon the dressing
release
and she goes nice how delicious
does that look wow what's daddy's policy
at home no waste no
waste no waste but now
smell that now oh wow
it doesn't smell like green beans it
smells like what is this oh thanks
how nice is that lovely amazing
right
that's the rice that's the green beans
[Music]
now i want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please
nice and generous with a sesame seed
i'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now all that's left
for your favorites to come out don't
those beans smell amazing
jack look at those beauties one for me
one for you three for me one for you
now i'd like you to sprinkle some spring
onions
on top please nice and generous
you transformed a very cheap and
cheerful chicken wing
yeah all right let me take them over
please do not drop them okay
jack let's go nice
this is my ultimate simple southeast
asian dinner
sticky spicy chicken wings thai green
curry rice
and fantastic beans with chili peanut
dressing guaranteed
to get the fussiest of eaters into
greens
that is the most amazing pork butt
that's away butts away now
this is incredible there's the shoulder
yeah and look
there's the shoulder blade if you go
through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called
a butt the slower you cook it the more
juicy it is
and it's great for big parties because
you just come along and get your fork
and
shred it a delicious smoky mayonnaise
and you're away onions into half and
half again
okay i'm gonna leave the roots on okay
because i want this to sit
underneath the pork it gives it a chance
to cook evenly it doesn't get dry in the
bottom really important
okay now i'll peel the garlic okay i'd
like you
and to crush the garlic we're gonna make
a really nice little paste
okay go on maggie
no come on come on come on nice good
girl
one more crush come on maggie i'm coming
sorry about that little cup there
now this is a beauty
paprika smoked paprika i love it so
three nice tablespoons
in okay two
large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt flakes and pepper good go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now olive oil
in
mix that some thyme in there so we've
got a sort of fragrant
rub time stalks underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom pour that
all over it now this is where you've got
to be really quick
okay and sort of rub that mushroom in
almost that's exactly that
smells amazing honestly you just drizzle
a little touch of olive oil on top of
that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinading of the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if i was
doing this for a sunday
and start marinating thursday friday so
it gets even tastier
right quite easy as well to make it's
very easy five and a half to six hours
in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are going to pimp some shop bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you have to twist
yeah there's so many things some of the
exciting things you can do with it right
salt pepper and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness
but there's some heat coming okay and
i've got a little bit
off you love this chipotle smoked
chipotle paste
i love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah can you
use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now
just have a little taste i've never had
this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard so
that's our nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready
just time to knock up a couple of tried
and tested party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water
skins and all meanwhile finely dice
sweet pickled gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty grilled cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush
and add your spring onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling
of grated greer these simple cheesy
crushed potatoes are equally delicious
served hot or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make a really nice
fresh broccoli salad now these are
called florets
that's the best part of the broccoli
okay the bit that everybody wants
once they're off i'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay you ever had raw broccoli before
it's always been cooked
really when you dress this with the
dressing it's incredible
now a little seasoning early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in
teaspoon of sugar please daddy a little
small
cider vinegar mmm there you go
finely chopped shallot in
with the broccoli so
pernicious roasted almonds into the
broccoli
currants i love them that gives that
nice sort of chewy texture
all right lift up your bowl please nice
and gently half of that
in the middle please thank you and stop
and then mix that up with me
good girl a little taste
so good and it's the kind of salad that
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow this
look at this
megan honestly that is amazing
it's beautiful that is incredible
now that goes to the table like that
that's delicious
just before we go to the table just a
little bit
honestly meg don't tell mom
thank you honestly do i do it i'm gonna
do it
that is incredible so good you promised
me you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple sides of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli
slaw
you